i'm thinking about the  famous hopper dance scene  which which seems surreal that really  took off in a way i did not expect and  then i remember thinking like oh it's  funny people are going to get really  into jim crotche now like people are  going to take the song and they're going  to really give georgia and instead they  got really into like me doing this dorky  thing and that was not my intention but  yeah it really took off  i love all the versions of it that  people started making for themselves  yeah there was a pretty funny thing  which i think it got taken down on  twitter where it was like hopper dancing  to and it was like different songs and  then him just doing this thing i thought  it was hilarious